good evening welcome to tucker carlson
tonight there is a
huge amount going on right now as you
know really a
torrent of news historic amounts to
begin tonight we are going to
ignore all of it we've never done that
before this is a news show brought to
you on a news
channel but on this second friday after
the election we'd like to take a
20-minute break from developments
so many things seem so completely
screwed up right now that it can be
overwhelming and over time it's also
misleading
if you pay too much attention to what's
happening you can easily conclude that
america is a rotten country
but that's wrong it's not america is
still the best there is
two things about america make it great
the country and its people
this is a truly beautiful place that's
the first thing
if you're absorbed in your phone all day
it's easy to forget that but look around
it's stunning switzerland has the alps
zimbabwe has victoria falls
but multiply that by an entire continent
and you've got
what we have america from the islands of
puget sound the islands in casco bay
to the rockies and the badlands the
upper peninsula and the appalachian
mountains in between
spend a day hiking through the shoshone
national forest in wyoming
you might not see another person how can
a place
so gorgeous be so empty we've got a lot
of those here
wake up in big sur california some
morning the smell of redwoods and salt
air will change you
you'll feel things you inherited from
your ancestors coming from places the
modern world cannot touch
we are blessed to live in a place like
this more blessed than we acknowledge
no matter what happens next no matter
who becomes the president
now or in the future nothing can
diminish the dignity of an eastern white
pine towering above the spruce in a new
england forest
all of it is ours to enjoy thank god
and we've got a lot of people to enjoy
it with an awful lot americans are still
the best people misguided as we
sometimes are
this isn't an especially religious
country anymore but surveys on church
going do not tell the whole story
even now most americans know they're not
really in charge of the universe
they know there's something bigger out
there bigger than all of us combined
and when you understand that when you
know in your bones how
small you are and how short the ride is
likely to be
you tend to treat people better
americans do
don't let cable news fool you don't let
us fool you
this is a profoundly nice country the
nicest
in the world americans are kind to
children
to pets to strangers we give more money
to charity than any other place
we tip our waiters more there's no
country on earth you'd rather be lost in
someone will help you in america we
don't eat dogs
we rescue them they sleep on the bed we
give them funny names we cry when they
die
it's a sweet country in some ways it's
getting better
the music's definitely improving so is
the food
believe it or not we still make things
here and a lot of them are pretty good
that probably won't change americans
love innovation but they're distrustful
of anyone's radical plans for the future
most people here don't want an abrupt
reshuffling of everything
they prefer incremental improvement
that's why we've had only one revolution
it's why we fought off the metric system
all these years and thank heaven we have
it's why we still have christmas and
always will
christmas in america is great even if
you don't really understand what it's
about and many people don't
it's still the happiest time of the year
and therefore it's the most american
america is a happy country despite
everything
our happiness is fundamental it's in our
founding documents
it's in our people nothing happening
tonight
can take that away